you see I found a
[Music]
prophecy yep and there she is the mother
of all asteroids screaming towards us
even going underground won't save us
this time how are we supposed to change
what is literally written in stone ah my
cynical friend the dinos were wiped off
the face of the Earth but some escaped
they changed their fate and we can
change else to
wa is it my time Angel time for what you
see there's this thing in the sky oh
that blinding light that seems to get
larger by the minute what about it seems
fine to me we're all about to die we are
young happy and safe and we always will
be thanks to
geotopia Kudos it is lovely now let's
figure out a way to launch it into space
I'm sorry you wanted destroy our home
it'll be destroyed either way bad news
somebody up there doesn't like
us I knew it I was right there's no
Paradise what I'm too young to go
extinct who's with
me so what do you think honestly I'm
worried the weasel's right no don't
listen to the weasel he's a raving Lon
sorry I just love Playing devil's ever
good let my mamals
pass why can't we just fear the
apocalypse like a normal
family but how do you tell someone
they're
doomed we're not doomed Buck it was just
a medeia shower and the show's over oh
quite the contrary old chap it's just
beginning hello welcome to a winter
Edition LED today we have brought the
cold in we're going to discuss a movie
called Ice Age and I have some awesome
guests today to come and discuss this
with me Caleb Oliver Haley Sophia and
Christopher welcome to the show so tell
me a little bit about you guys um do you
know anything about this movie heard
about ice age but um I've never heard of
I've never watched this um specific
movie I made seen like a little bit of
like the first one or something like
that but I haven't watched this all
right anyone else seen any of these yeah
I haven't I've heard of it I've heard
people talking about it but I haven't
really
seen it like yeah I haven't seen it okay
good so this will be kind of fresh to
you how about you guys I haven't seen it
or watched it I've seen ads okay but
besides that no so you know what it is I
know what it is a little bit okay I've
seen I think a lot of them in the past I
have I haven't seen this specific one
but I do know I'm very familiar with Ice
Age I've watched several of these in the
past also but I haven't seen it in like
the past two years okay so this will be
kind of a refresher for some of you guys
some of you guys haven't seen this at
all but if you've seen any work that our
ministry has done we analyze these
things by putting on the biblical
glasses uh we're going to watch a couple
clips and then I want to know what you
guys think what you guys see do you see
anything spiritual in some of these
clips if you can think about some of the
biblical things that come to mind when
you watch it all right the
universe a vast expanse of space and
matter it includes all that we see and
all that we
know since the beginning of time we have
wondered how it came to be a gloriously
orchestrated plan a chance series of
events or something much much
Dumber all right
what did we just hear it was like asking
how the world came and then stating some
like like reasons why like was it by
chance was it Dumber or something like
that and good was it a Divine Design was
it orchestrated in some way right which
would be basically be like God created
the world right or something much dumber
than that now when you say something is
much dumber than that what does that
make you think
irrelevant stupid so of course they're
discussing the end of the world as they
know it the ice age is is uh is it a
Christian worldview is it a creative
worldview is it an evolutionary
worldview what do you think I think it's
part this well to this movie it's
partially um creative and it's
evolutionary yes okay they're obviously
showing animals that do those animals
exist now no no so they're extinct right
so of course they are discussing these
uh these animals and how they became
extinct all right so here's a little
clip just to show you kind of what what
is going on in the
story look there's more
coming meteor shower the cave get inside
move move
[Music]
what are you doing here well I what I'm
trying but how do you tell someone
they're
doomed we're not doomed Buck it was just
a media shower and the show's over oh
quite the contrary old chap it's just
beginning you see I found a
[Music]
prophecy all right what do you guys
think it's in interesting that they have
the meteor shower as like not kind of
the flood and a reason as to why the
dinosaurs were wiped out cu that's what
a lot of I think evolutionists say is
that the dinosaurs were wiped out by
meteors or meteor shower right and he's
reading something that was this big
Stone item right and he's saying that he
found a what prophecy prophecy what what
do you think of when you think of
Prophecy Revelation maybe the Book of
Daniel okay so give me a prophecy y that
you know of in the Bible about the world
well Jesus is going to come okay what
happens to the world then well disaster
starts happening like different things
like earthquakes meteor showers
interesting right the end of the world
is prophesied in the Bible right and
there is an interesting prophecy can you
think of a prophecy where a rock is
going to come and in King
Nebuchadnezzar's dream King nebar dream
right destroyed the um Idol destroyed
the idol and what did that symbolize
Jesus's Kingdom coming yes Jesus's
Kingdom so what was the prophecies
really going over and talking about what
what what aspect of the world the End of
Time the end of time right but it showed
the different kingdoms that were going
to exist right until there was a final
Kingdom that would come and be set up
and be an everlasting Kingdom right
here's what he says about this prophecy
let me get this straight instead of
running away from a deadly asteroid you
want us to run directly towards it I
know it sounds suboptimal but the good
news is it'll kill us no better where we
went well that's reassuring okay but
even if we get to the crash site how are
we supposed to change what is literally
written in stone ah my cynical friend
the dinos were wiped off the face of the
Earth but some escaped they change their
fate and we can change us too so the
information that's being told to you is
there's a prophecy that the end of the
world is coming from this rock that's
hitting it and what does he say he can
try to do he can stop it he can stop it
right do you think that there's a
prophecy in the Bible that is what's
going to happen in the end of the world
do we have any control over that no
control not at all right in fact this is
what it says in the prophecy of Daniel
which you brought up Christopher you saw
O King Behold a great image this image
Mighty and exceeding bright
stood before you and it appeared as it
appearance was frightening the head of
the image was with gold and its chest
and its arms and its silver and its made
its thighs of bronze and its legs of
iron and its feet partly of iron and
partly of clay as you looked a stone was
cut out by no human hand and it struck
the image on its feet of iron and clay
and it broke them into pieces and then
the iron and the clay and the bronze and
the silver and the gold all together
were broken into pieces and became like
chaff of the Sun summer threshing floors
and the wind carried them away so that
not a trace of them could be found but
the stone that struck the image became a
great mountain and filled the whole
earth that's the prophecy of the stone
that is going to basically set up the
kingdom now who's the stone Jesus Jesus
Jesus right in fact the Bible describes
him as a rock so this is kind of an
interesting parallel that they're kind
of beginning to discuss end of the world
this is happening he's basically saying
he can change and not die like he can
change the end of the world change
what's written in stone something that's
written in stone out is that biblical
language or not yeah the Ten
Commandments were written Ten
Commandments written in stone right
something that's written that cannot be
changed and here they're discussing now
the whole movie begins to unfold in a
way of how do we stop the end of the
world that's really what's going on here
okay so this is what Isaiah 5511 says so
shall my word that goes out from my
mouth it shall not return to me empty
but it shall accomplish that which I
purpose and shall succeed in the thing
which I sent it what does that
mean me whatever I guess God or Jesus
says it will come to pass and it will be
made it will be fulfilled so if there's
a prophecy that something in the end of
the world is going to happen will it
happen yes or no yes yes we cannot
change it absolutely we can't change it
there's nothing that we can do to
actually prevent or stop any of that
right okay so this is kind of an
interesting story right here we go
Malachi 41 Christopher can you read this
for behold the day is coming burning
like an oven when all the arrogant and
evildoers will be stubble the day that
is coming shall set them Ablaze says the
Lord of hosts so that it will leave them
neither root nor Branch now what is this
talking about the fire at the end of the
world the fire at the end of the world
right there's a fire at the end of the
world that is going to basically burn up
all the the existing things of the world
and all of the evil that's ever been
done on this planet and it's going to
reset it for something new right that's
what this is ha this that's what this is
talking about well that also happens to
be what the storyline is in this story
now what kind of an animal is this looks
like some kind of bird Dinosaur Mix okay
bird Dinosaur Mix uh we have a term for
that what do you call that dragon a
dragon right what color is this Dragon
red and gray red and gray yeah well
maybe my TV uh portrays it a little bit
of gray but you'll see a little bit
later what color he is he is a scarlet
color and he's also purple there's a
reason for this I believe let me show
you if we stop the weasel and his
friends from diverting the asteroid
kaboy it kills the weasel and everyone
else while we Glide safely above it all
it'll be our
Paradise now interesting so this is sort
of the villain character of the story
and notice how he says what's going to
happen when all the world is burning
where where are they going to be gliding
safely above is there going to be people
that are gliding safely above the world
as it is burning yes the Christians yes
so kind of interesting right and where
where does the Bible what does it say
about the dragon who's the dragon Satan
Satan right but it's interesting how
they're kind of playing with this
character because the dragon in the
Bible is typically spoken of of Satan
but is he wanting to end the world this
Dragon yes yes so does the dragon in the
Bible want to end the world yes yeah
does he think about it no he doesn't in
fact in Revelation it talks about when
there's fire that comes down from heaven
it talks about that Dragon he's trying
to prevent that he's trying to stop that
but the fire comes down so what does it
say right here Caleb can you read this
for me but the day of the Lord will come
like a thief and then the heavens will
pass away with a Roar and the heavenly
bodies will be burned up and dissolved
and the earth and the works that are
done on it will be exposed so the Bible
describes a time when the world will
burn right this is what this is speaking
of there's also a little bit later it it
continues
on SO waiting for and hastening the
coming of the day of God because of the
heavens will be set on fire and
dissolved and the heavenly bodies will
melt as they burn so the Bible describes
the end of the world say time that the
world will be burning but what will
happen to all of the Christians Haley
can you go ahead and read this then I
saw Thrones and seating on them were
those to whom the authority to judge was
committed also I saw the souls of those
who had been beheaded for the testimony
of Jesus and for the word of God and
those who had not worshiped the Beast or
its image and had not received its mark
on their foreheads or their hands they
came to life and reign with Christ for
years the rest of the Dead did not come
to life until the thousand years were
ended this is the first resurrection
blessed and holy is the one who shares
in the first resurrection over such the
second death has no power but they will
be priest of God and of Christ and they
will reign with him for a thousand years
so isn't it interesting that the picture
that it gives them is these people will
be reigning on what does it say Thrones
on Thrones right and what did they just
show you the dragon was sitting on
Throne a throne and he's going to be
high up in the sky while the rest of the
world is burning now this is interesting
where they're kind of starting to share
with you who's trying to save the world
and who's trying to destroy the world
okay so here's the dragons and if you'll
notice their colors again right I just
want to point this out because we'll
talk about that in a biblical sense in
just a second but listen to what they
say now let's make sure that asteroid
hits
why can't we just fear the apocalypse
like a normal
family all right so they fly off into
the sky they're really letting you know
that these are actual dragons and a
dragon can fly right that's kind of the
the imagery that they're giving you to
and they're flying off into the sky
right so here is a very interesting clip
here of a young couple that wants to get
married and they find that the end of
the world is going to happen and so
they're talking about there being you
know no wedding and and that there'll be
no existence Beyond this so listen to
what these guys
say
Julian I want you to know that if we
don't make it if we never get married
you were the only one for me hey come on
of course we'll make it and we will get
married but maybe it's the Universe
telling us we won't whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa you're going to let
one tiny little 300 M wide asteroid ruin
your plans how can we think about our
future when we may not have one hey
we're going to stop this thing and
you'll get married B bing bada boom well
not boom forget I said
boom I know I'll be your wedding planner
it'll take your mind off all this end of
the world stuff all right so they're
saying let's just have a wedding let's
not think about the end of the world why
is that interesting biblically speaking
do you know at the end of time they'll
be marrying and giving in marriage
perfect
you guys are seeing this as well okay go
ahead and read this Sophia but of that
day and hour no one knows not even the
angels of heaven but my father only but
as the days of Noah were so also will
the coming of the son of man be for as
in the days before the flood they were
eating and drinking marrying and giving
in marriage until the day that Noah
entered the Ark and did not know until
the flood came and took them all away
so also will the coming of the son of
man be so isn't that kind of an
interesting little thing that they're
discussing in this story like don't
don't don't worry about the end of the
world right let's let's plan a wedding
and let's let's keep this going and
that's kind of something that the Bible
speaks about will happen in the end
people will be married and given in
marriage and this will be happening in
the end now here's another little scene
that there's a lot of little biblical
imagery that they're putting in here but
um maybe you guys can tell me what story
this comes from let my mammals pass
that's never going to
work the Ancients grant us safe
passage
sweet all right what is this from Moses
Moses right yeah and and that was a um
foreshadowing basically right of us
walking to the what what did they what
what was Moses and leading everybody to
promis Promised Land rich is a symbol of
what heaven heaven right and it's
interesting that they threw that little
imagery in here as well so they're
definitely discussing some Bible things
um I just want you to see as well um
this particular little weasel character
right here he finds this pumpkin and he
thinks that this pumpkin is his baby I
don't know where they came up with this
story but it's it's kind of an odd thing
but I want you to just listen to the
words that are said and listen to how
the dragon is jealous of this
pumpkin lucky pumpkin must be nice to
have a loving
father okay here we go you can do this
Roger yay
kidnapping look I'm sorry it's it's not
me I would never do something like this
it's my father he's crazy all right why
is that significant of what he just said
right there he doesn't have a loving
father he doesn't have a loving father
right and his father wants to do what to
the world destroy it so which father is
going to destroy the world in the end of
time God God right so it's planting this
kind of seed of an idea of you know what
that's not a very loving thing to do and
they just put these little ideas in
there and he's describing that his
father is not a loving father okay so
here is another little scene that's kind
of very
interesting huh that's not the weasel
that's I don't know what that is H
whoa is it my time Angel time for
what what do you think about that
interesting it depends interesting the
dragon as an angel puts the dragon as an
angel that that that you see this Dragon
coming with the light flashing by him
and around him and stuff but it's really
the dragon right all these things are
little tiny pieces of imagery and if
you're not familiar with where these
kind of Concepts come from they get
placed inside of your mind right and
this is what the Bible says go ahead and
read this oliv so he carried me away in
the spirit Into the Wilderness and I saw
a woman sitting on the Scarlet Beast
which was full of names as BL of
blasphemy having seven heads and seven
and 10 horns the woman was array in
purple and Scarlet and adorned with gold
pre and precious stones and Pearls so
what is this describing the dragons like
that they show in the movie The Dragon
purple and Scarlet right but what is
that a symbol of in our real life in our
real world not this particular world
what is the purple and the Scarlet the
Catholic Church the Catholic church
right do you know that there is a lot of
movies that pop this kind of imagery
into it of purple and Scarlet and here
is if I want you to think of this when
you see the dragon with purple and
Scarlet they did this in the
Transformers movie um when they were
when um Optimus Prime was riding on what
looked like a dragon it he was purple
and Scarlet and this is kind of a very
interesting imagery but listen to what
uh this this uh little thing says right
here I'm coming to the light can't wait
to see all those relatives I hate wo get
off get off get off demon
Angel and that's how it's
done
hello angel am I in heaven so they're
making a little funny scene right but
isn't that interesting that she called
it a what is it a demon Angel a demon
Angel right so they're putting this
imagery in there that this is like
something evil right now remember
remember that the dragon in the Bible is
a representation of Satan right and the
woman that's ordained in purple and
Scarlet what is she a symbol of the
Catholic churchur the church right here
is a picture of what imagery has if a
woman and a Scarlet riding the dragon
and this is the imagery that's that's in
the Bible does anybody know what this is
from this here is a picture of The
Hunchback of notredam the woman that's
in there and it's interesting that she's
in purple and Scarlet and in a biblical
sense it's interesting that the Bible
describes purple and Scarlet for a
particular Church look at what colors
come out of that church that's pretty
fascinating to
me how about
this if you start looking at a lot of
the women that are in a lot of these
cartoons what color do you notice
they're wearing purple and Scarlet is a
common theme that they will put the
woman in now what colors do you notice
her wearing purple and Scarlet purple
and Scarlet okay so this is now one of
the characters that comes into the scene
in this in this particular story and
they're going to talk with her and she
is a follower of this particular
character that's going to be shown to
you right now okay so they believe that
they have an uh opportunity to save the
world with this person and this is the
person that they're talking about if we
don't do something fast that asteroid is
going to blow us all to
Smither oh that sounds urgent i' better
take you to him who's him your leader he
is our everything he sees all he knows
all so she says she's going to take him
to a leader she describes him as him she
says he sees all and he knows all who in
the Bible can see everything and knows
everything
God Only God right the devil can't see
everything he doesn't know everything
right and so it's very interesting that
this is the character that they're going
to introduce to the story right here and
go ahead Caleb read this for if our
heart condemns us God is greater than
our hearts and knows all things and
knows all things so God knows all things
and Oliver go ahead and read this one
the eyes of the Lord are in every place
keeping watch on the evil and the good
okay Haley go ahead and read this and no
creature is hidden from his sight but
all are naked and exposed to the eyes of
him to whom we must give account and who
is this speaking about God Only God
right he sees everything he knows
everything so it's interesting that this
is the character that they're going to
introduce that he is somebody who knows
everything and sees everything and here
he is they're introducing to him right
now here he is the master of meditation
the Supreme Serene the four-time heavy
thoughts champion of the
world
Wonder so where is he he is here talking
to you we're all about to die well
that's no good stress is a killer let us
loosen our Limbs and open our minds uh
seriously you see there's this thing in
the sky oh that blinding light that
seems to get larger by the minute what
about it seems fine to me uh with all
due respect your twistin that's an
asteroid it's magnetically attracted to
this place and it's heading straight for
us it must desire our magnetic crystals
well who can blame it they're really
quite something did you know their power
grants Eternal youth so what is the
pieces of information they just told you
here that it's like this is supposed to
be like the one who knows all and it's a
goat which is the symbol of Satan in the
Bible which is interesting right they
are making fun of the fact that he's
like the dolly llama in in fact in here
that his name is llama right but a llama
does not have horns so only the only
animal that has horns is a male sheep
he's a male sheep what do you notice
about his coloring rainbow he's a
rainbow what do what do you what do you
think the Bible describes Jesus as what
does he look like have you ever read the
description that John gives in
Revelation thing about a rainbow it is a
rainbow in fact listen to what it says
here I saw saw another Mighty angel
coming down from heaven clothed with a
cloud and a rainbow was on his head and
his face was like the sun and his feet
were like the pillars of fire Jesus
actually has a rainbow color around his
head and so I find it very interesting
that they made him what colors do you
notice he has red orange yellow green
blue he's missing a little bit of blue
he has the purple and a little bit of
indigo but isn't that kind of
interesting that they would make the
goat llama lamb character that knows
everything sees everything this is kind
of a twisted representation of Jesus and
he would be the one that they are saying
he can save them from everything now
listen to this we are young happy and
safe and we always will be so they're
young happy and safe as long as they
live with him in this Crystal Palace
that he lives in now how the devil are
we going to launch these crystals you
can it's
impossible I am
bushed awesome meeting you guys feel
free to hang or you know
whatever H that's it he was our last
hope we're doomed I wanted to point
something out about this what do you
think about this
scene it looks like an upside down heart
I look like an upside down heart okay
what what is the shape of this what is
he saying it was maybe it's the Tree of
Life yes he said I'm bushed I am
bushed and he's a bush now why would
that be interesting in light of what we
just learned about this
character who showed up in a bush God
God more specifically who spoke with
Moses was it Jesus or God that was Jesus
that spoke with Moses isn't that kind of
interesting that he turns himself into
the shape of a book
that's kind of a really random scene but
I think they're kind of showing you the
imagery of who they're actually meaning
this character to be so the sloth ends
up um getting in this Crystal Palace
thing and he wants a a particular um
rock that he wants to give to this girl
that he wants to marry and he ends up
hurting or destroying this little
Crystal Palace and listen to this 300
years of peace and Harmony undone by one
colossally incredibly
stupendously stupid
sloth I'm really sorry Mr
llama sorry sorry sorry doesn't fix the
wall now does it you
little I need a bubble bath or massage
who knows acupuncture I need to let my
anger out let it out he was this llama
that was basically this very calm and
Serene does anybody know what the word
serenity
means means calm and I looked it up in
the dictionary and listen to this it is
a title given to a reigning Prince or a
dignitary isn't that interesting so she
says so much for uh this Serene and this
uh calm person that that that this llama
was supposed to be and now he becomes an
angry llama why is that interesting can
you think of anything in the Bible that
talks about an Angry
Lamb so he becomes an angry llama and
the Bible tells us in Revelation that
the kings of the Earth the Great Men the
rich men the commanders the Mighty Men
every slave and every free man hid
themselves in the caves that were in the
rocks and the mountains and the mountain
they said to the mountains and the Rocks
Fallen us and hide us from the face of
him who sits on the throne and from the
what the Wrath of the Lamb isn't that
interesting that right in the end of
time we have a picture of that lamb that
was slain for us is coming back with
vengeance upon the end of the world and
that's the picture that they're giving
to you that this lamb is angry and ah he
has to let his anger out out I find that
kind of very interesting and they're
also kind of putting these other little
imagery ideas in here listen to what the
LA the lamb says we need all the
crystals loaded into the volcano Pronto
what no I'm not giving you my crystals
we need them to rebuild our
Sanctuary all right what did he just say
to rebuild our Sanctuary what does that
have to do with anything there's a
sanctuary in heaven there's a sanctuary
right and that's in connection to God
and so I found that very interesting
that they would even use that little
terminology but here's what all of the
animals then decide to
do may I remind you geotopia is not
yours to keep no you may not it came
from the sky and now it's time to give
it back it's not it's too you old coot
change isn't easy but it's part of life
it's time for us to embrace it again
whether you like it or not not so what
is that piece of information that they
just told you right here he said it came
from the sky yes and that we need to do
what change we need to change does God
like
change No in fact what does the Bible
say about God and changing God is
unchanging he's unchanging right he
doesn't change at all and so as she's
sitting there telling him you need to to
accept that there's this change and he
says I don't like that right here's what
the Bible truth is of that Hebrews 138
says Jesus Christ is the same yesterday
and today and forever more Malachi also
talks for I the Lord do not change so
it's interesting that they're putting
that imagery into this story now here's
the end of the world as this thing is
coming I want you to look at like what
this thing looks like in the sky as it's
coming towards the
Earth bad news somebody up there doesn't
like we're 6 minutes behind
shedule double time everyone we need
that big Crystal does God Like Us yes
yes right and to look at the end of the
world is this going to be something that
we want because we want to end
sin why why why would you put an idea
out there that says somebody up there
does not like us that's that's that's
kind of like pointing the finger at God
and being like he's coming to end the
world he doesn't like us right almost
like
gnosticism yeah it's kind of really
flipping this idea upside down it's like
you know because he's coming to end the
world he's mean and it puts this just
little seed of a thought in your mind
but does God actually really love us yes
yes how do we know he says yeah he died
for the cross on us he died for our
place think about this has anyone else
in heaven ever died
no no one who's the only being that's
ever died from Heaven at all Jesus Jesus
so that we would have an opportunity to
live life so that we could have a chance
if we wanted to to go to heaven with God
right does that mean that he loves us or
he doesn't like us he loves us so a
statement like that puts an idea into
young children's Minds yeah somebody up
there they don't like us because they're
coming to destroy
us we got company
sorry about this I'm really conflicted
right now that's more like it Roger now
finish him wait wait you don't
understand you see that if that asteroid
hits we all die if it hits we all
die that's where you're wrong see while
you run for your mammal lives we'll be
high in the sky cruising above it all
that's the stupidest thing I ever
heard I knew it I was right there's no
Paradise what I'm too young to go
extinct she gets it now please we
haven't got much time what are you
waiting for kill him no dad I won't let
you do you want to know what I love
about our family that we're alive there
are more important things in your pride
right now if you care about us you
should not kill him you should help help
him dad as a father I would work with my
worst enemy to ensure a brighter future
for my little
[Music]
one reinforcements have
arrived what is
happening they're now teaming up with
the dragon now they're teaming up with
the dragon to stop to stop the end of
the world they were enemies at one point
in time and isn't that interesting that
the Bible gives us a picture of the
dragon and the woman that was writing
the dragon right as working together in
the end of time and how do they portray
him they use the word
father and you shouldn't kill them dad
right who's going to end the end of life
at the end of the world God God it's God
it's not the devil actually it's God
that's making that choice and so this is
kind of putting this imagery in your
mind that you know what I would work
with my worst enemy if it meant saving
life right that kind of puts God in a
bad light if God's not going to to save
the world and if this worst enemy wants
to save the world does that make sense
and they also brought out that um
there's no Paradise there's no Paradise
you heard that right so think about all
those little things that get put into
your mind when you watch this thing like
what it's all fake oh see there's no end
of the world world and there's no
there's no um prize at the end yeah good
catch all right so here's the very ended
[Music]
we did it we did it
in your face Space Rock yeah
baby hit the road you stupid rock we
just stopped the Doom all right what do
you notice about this Satan wins
basically that's what they're saying yes
and they stopped what the Doomsday Clock
what time is the Doomsday
Clock yes but what time is
it 12 12 12 o'clock what does the bible
describe as the end of the world
midnight the Midnight Hour right right
isn't that interesting that they're
basically like we prevented the end of
the world and everybody's like Yay but
in a biblical sense do we want to
prevent the end of the world no no
because what does that mean for us truly
we go to heaven eternal life eternal
life and that we get a chance to never
have these problems exist on this place
again it's crazy how they like use so
much biblical stuff while like deceiving
you into thinking that like there's no
eternal life or there's no God or
there's like whatever right God is bad
Satan's good right right and it just
kind of really like puts some Twisted
ideas into your into your mind about
what the end of the world is like or you
know how can we stop this or you know
what what is is there a paradise or you
know what is the Lamb I mean all of
those concepts are get kind of like
really jumbled up in in something like
this and um so uh I thought that was
pretty crazy
but uh you know we want to be sure that
we are keeping our eyes open and be
thinking about these things you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of movies
a lot of cartoons that put these kind of
spiritual ideas into your brain and and
you know we spend a lot of time going to
church and reading our Bibles and trying
to learn what the truth is and those
things we want to keep in our minds but
you know there's a lot of other ideas
out there that are being placed into our
minds as well and we want to be careful
of those thank thank you guys for
watching what do you guys think of this
uh we want to hear about it in the
comments below please uh if you see
anything that's you know something
biblical in in uh one of these that we
might have missed let us know in the
comments below we'd love to hear your
guys' thoughts but as always think of
these things put on your biblical eyes
and uh we hope that you got a blessing
from today's conversation thank you guys
for helping and uh maybe we'll do this
again sometime
[Music]